[Musik]
Kolumbien liegt zwischen dem Pazifik und
dem karibischen Meer und ist heute ein
schlüsselstandort in Bezug auf die
Wirtschaftskrise in Venezuela der
ehemalige Präsident von Kolumbien Juan
Manuel Santos der 2016 den Nobelpreis
bekam für seinen Plan den 50-Jährigen
Bürgerkrieg gegen die Fahrt zu beenden
trat 2018 nach zwei Amtszeiten zurück
heute steht Kolumbien wirtschaftlich
besser da als Venezuela und andere
Länder in Lateinamerika
[Musik]
der Aufstieg der kryptowährungen kam mit
dem neuen kolumbianischen Präsidenten
Ivan Duke und seinem Versprechen die
Steuern für Krypto und Datenbank
blockchain Unternehmen zu senken die
Nachricht wurde am 29 August von der
lokalen Zeitung El Tiempo veröffentlicht
ich fahre diesmal nach Medellin der
zweitgrößten Stadt Kolumbiens Medellin
hat eine geschätzte Bevölkerung von 2,5
Millionen Menschen die Positionen als
sekundäre Industriestadt in Kolumbien
war einer der wichtigsten Faktoren um
die Krise in den 80er und 90er Jahren zu
überwinden
die Metro ein massiver öffentlicher
Verkehrsdienst ist heute der Stolz der
Stadt
Medellin ist auch bekannt als Stadt des
ewigen Frühlings wegen des tollen
Wetters das ganze Jahr über und es Basis
einer der aktivsten dash-gemeinden der
Welt
Medellin ist auch das Zuhause von coin
Logic ATM solution
Eduards Eigentümer von Dash red Samuel
Barbosa Dash teamentwickler und George
Donnelly Eigentümer von Dash kolumbia
mein Ziel ist es herauszufinden wie die
Entwicklung in Kolumbien abgelaufen ist
von einem einzigen Geschäft das im
januar 2018 Dash akzeptierte bis zu den
mehr als 350 Unternehmen die es heute
sind und wie Kolumbien eins der
wichtigsten Länder war während der
Wirtschaftskrise in Venezuela
bis heute hat Kolumbien Millionen von
Flüchtlingen aus Venezuela aufgenommen
und es spielt eine unglaublich wichtige
Rolle in dieser schrecklichen
humanitären Krise
auch die dash-gemeinde arbeitet an einem
Bildungsprogramm um eine Lösung zu
finden für die Menschen Massen die nach
Kolumbien kommen
[Musik]
sie sind hier einfach um zu arbeiten um
Geld zu verdienen um es dann ihren
Familien in Venezuela zu schicken wir
können nicht mehr nur hoffen glauben
oder dem System der Regierung oder den
Banken vertrauen
wir brauchen kryptowährungen und wir
brauchen sie jetzt
[Musik]
wir sind früh raus heute und unser Ziel
ist es zwischen 10 und 15 Läden in der
Stadt zu finden ihren Status zu prüfen
und sie für Dash zu gewinnen
diesmal wurde ich auch von der Gemeinde
eingeladen auf ihren Events zu sprechen
und ich wurde von Nelson Kamera von
camera technologies begleitet
außerdem waren Lorenzo Aurelia von Dash
Venezuela und orenia Cala die Gründerin
von Dash Venezuela dabei
wir nahmen einige Taxis und fuhren durch
die ganze Stadt um zu sehen wie der
erste Kontakt zu neuen Händlern ist und
wie Dash angenommen wird
wie geht man auf die Händler zu geht man
selbst hin oder schickt man jemanden um
sie davon zu überzeugen dieses magische
internetgeld zu verwenden gib uns einen
Tipp
also ich gehe hin und sage ihnen dass
das digitale Geld Dash in Medellin
angekommen ist jede Woche geben wir
Leuten ein bisschen Dash und sie suchen
nach Orten wo sie es ausgeben können ich
möchte Ihnen neue Kunden bringen und ich
erzähle Ihnen alles was Sie über der
schwissen müssen
ich sorge dafür dass sie kein Geld
verlieren wollen sie es versuchen unser
ganzes Team hier ist sehr erfolgreich
mit diesem Ansatz denn welcher
Geschäftsmann will keine neuen Kunden
ich war bisher in ein paar Restaurants
hier in Medellin die Dash akzeptieren
nach dem Event heute Abend werde ich mir
das ansehen es gibt sogar einen ganzen
Supermarkt wo man bedesch zahlen kann
das ist aufregend und es ist interessant
zu sehen wie sich kryptowährungen in
dritte weltländern schneller verbreitet
als in Europa oder den USA wie sehen sie
diese Entwicklung und wo glauben sie
wird Medellin in Sachen Dash in ein paar
Monaten stehen
ich denke das wird ziemlich verrückt
unsere größte Herausforder ist jetzt wie
wir den Leuten Dash sicher verkaufen
können denn sie wollen das
glücklicherweise haben wir hier ein
Partnerunternehmen coin Logic das
verteilt Geldautomaten in der ganzen
Stadt ich denke jeden Tag ich habe hier
keine Kontrolle mehr das passiert alles
ohne mich aber das ist gut
von Tür zu Tür gehen ist eine extrem
harte Aufgabe zum ersten Mal auf einen
Händler zuzugehen oder mit jemandem
erneut Kontakt aufzunehmen der Dash
akzeptiert aber noch keine Kunden hat
sometimes manchmal hören wir ja sie sind
sehr willkommen und das einzurichten und
unser Geschäft in die dash-gemeinde
aufzunehmen aber manchmal hören wir auch
nein wir sind noch nicht interessiert
also geht der Rundgang weiter und nach
einem langen Tag ist es Zeit nach Hause
zu gehen und sich etwas auszuruhen
[Musik]
Veranstaltungstage sind immer meine
liebsten Tage in der Woche
hunderte von Menschen kommen um zu
verstehen was kryptowährungen sind und
was Dash ist
und es ist die Gelegenheit für sie ein
Wallet runterzuladen und ihre ersten
Erfahrungen mit Dash zu machen
ich fasse das auch in einer Präsentation
zusammen spreche über die Geschichte des
Geldes und wie wichtig es ist zu
verstehen das Geld heute nur ein Blatt
Papier ist
auf dieser Veranstaltung lief es genauso
und es waren einige Leute von Dash
Columbia Dash Venezuela und Dash Brasil
dabei
ein teamentwickler und Mitglieder der
örtlichen dash-gemeinde die schon dabei
helfen ein kryptowährungssystem in
Medellin zu etablieren
[Musik]
während der Veranstaltung hatten wir in
einem anderen Konferenzraum rund 30
Geschäftsleute die schon Dash
akzeptieren
sie bildeten einen Teil des Events weil
sie über ihre täglichen Erfahrungen mit
der kryptowährung berichten konnten
es war eine tolle Gelegenheit
verschiedene Produkte mit Dash zu kaufen
aber am wichtigsten das Mittagessen auf
dem Händler treffen
hinter mir ist eine der berühmtesten
verwählers von Caracas eine Art Marke
der Hauptstadt Venezuelas niemand kann
sagen wie viele Menschen in diesen Slums
leben
[Musik]
wir haben gehört das Lebensmittelketten
wie Papa john's Subway kryptowährung
akzeptieren wir werden das jetzt mal
ausprobieren dieser Aufkleber hier heißt
eigentlich dass die kryptowährung
akzeptieren hallo was ist das ich kann
mit Dash Bezahlen im Moment geht das
leider nicht ich brauche ein Smartphone
um den Code zu scannen den sie auf ihren
Telefon erhalten um die Transaktion
abzuschließen aber der Chef hat das
Handy mitgenommen wie viele Personen
bezahlen hier mit kryptowährung ist das
beliebt
wenn die Ausrüstung am Wochenende hier
ist haben wir manchmal vier Leute an
einem Tag
auf meiner Reise durch Venezuela stellte
sich heraus wie unbequemes ist jedes Mal
wenn ich etwas einkaufen möchte
entweder musste ich jemandem mein Handy
geben damit er es hinter der Kasse
einscannen kann oder ich musste darauf
warten dass der Manager oder Eigentümer
mit seinem eigenen Smartphone kommt um
die Zahlung anzunehmen
es gab einen Vertrauensproblem entweder
wollten Besitzer ihr eigenes
Mobiltelefon nicht den Mitarbeitern
überlassen oder ihnen nicht erlauben das
eigene Handy zu nehmen und das Wallet
runterzuladen um am Ende des Tages die
Transaktionen zu übertragen ein weiteres
Problem waren Händler die ihre wallets
ausdrucken und den ganzen Tag offen
liegen ließen so dass jeder genau sehen
konnte wie viele Transaktionen getätigt
worden waren und wie viel Dash sie
eingenommen hatten
im Moment funktioniert das noch aber um
die Kapazität von
QR-Code scanning und der blockchain
Technologie zu nutzen um
Sekundenschnelle Dash Transaktionen zu
ermöglichen würden wir eine bessere
Lösung brauchen
also fingen wir an etwas zu entwickeln
dass wir heute Elektro payen
in diesem Moment schließen wir die
Entwicklung in unserem Werk in China ab
und schon bald werden wir 25.000
Einheiten pro Monat herstellen können
während unserer Woche in Kolumbien
besorgten ich und nennt so ein kameda
der Entwickler dieses Abrechnungssystems
ein paar Prototypen um sie zu testen und
Händlern zu zeigen sie lieben es und
wollten es sofort kaufen und jetzt sehen
Sie mal wie einfach dieses
kostengünstige Abrechnungssystem
funktioniert
[Musik]
aber wie kommen wir von einem Händler
der Dash akzeptiert im januar 2018 zu
mehr als 350 Unternehmen in weniger als
zwölf Monaten
oder indem wir eine Anzeige bei Google
oder Facebook schalten
dieser Prozess erfordert tausende von
Stunden hunderte von treffen hohe
managementskompetenz tägliche Schulungen
von Händlern und Ladenbesitzern und
jedes einzelnen Mitarbeiters
haben ihnen zu zeigen wie der Download
und das digitale dashquallet
funktionieren
man braucht das direkte Gespräch mit
jedem einzelnen muss ihm dieselbe
Geschichte erzählen in wenigen Minuten
alles über Geld Wirtschaft und
Technologie erklären
das ist eine Menge Arbeit vom ersten
Kontakt zum Händler über den zweiten
Besuch bis hin zum Abschluss wenn wir
den Laden mit Aufklebern und wallets
ausrüsten und vor allem Sie darüber
informieren dass Sie jetzt teil eines
globalen Netzwerks sind es ist auch sehr
wichtig jedem Ladenbesitzer zu erklären
wie Sie Ihre Buchhaltung führen und wo
sie die digitale Währung in Papiergeld
eintauschen können um ihre Lieferanten
und Mitarbeiter zu bezahlen
die Zeit die wir in dieses Projekt
investieren all die Arbeitsstunden all
die Stunden unterwegs jeder einzelne
Händler zählt jedes einzelne treffen
zählt jede einzelne Person jeder
einzelne Download eines wallets und vor
allem all die Enthusiasten und die
Menschen die das kryptowährungssystem
laufen bringen wollen und die vielen
treffen und Schulungen sind dafür da um
sicherzustellen dass jeder weiß wie man
einen Wallet runterlädt wie man einen
Backup macht und sein Kapital in
geeigneter Weise sichert
wenn man die Bodenhaftung behält und auf
die Händler zugeht dann merkt man dass
Hunderte von Ihnen bereit sind ihre
Räumlichkeiten zur Verfügung zu stellen
für Meetings Veranstaltungen und
individuelle Schulungen
all das wurde auch sehr professionelle
Weise gemacht und vor allem alles wurde
abgerechnet
heute haben wir in unserem dash-netzwerk
weitere Mitarbeiter die jeden einzelnen
Antrag überprüfen um sicherzustellen
dass das Kapital auf faire Weise
ausgegeben wird
heute ist der Columbia geführt von
George Donnelly das beste Beispiel für
gute Führung innerhalb unseres Netzwerks
hallo ich bin George Donnelly ich bin
vor 11 Wochen losgezogen um zu beweisen
dass die groß angelegte Einführung von
kryptowährung nicht nur möglich ist
sondern dass die Leute danach hungern
und dass das sehr effektiv und
nachhaltig und zu geringen Kosten geht
und wir haben es geschafft
vor elf Wochen gab es noch keinen
einzigen dashändler in Kolumbien dem
Land mit der drittstärksten Bevölkerung
in Lateinamerika und Nachbar von
Venezuela
heute gibt es mehr als 95
[Musik]
40 Prozent sind Restaurants
26 Prozent sind Einzelhandelsgeschäfte
und der Rest ist alles mögliche vom
Barbier und Schneider bis hin zur
Motorradwerkstatt und einem Hotel
dieses Mal das sind kleine Läden mit
weniger als fünf Mitarbeitern in denen
auch der Eigentümer regelmäßig anwesend
ist
wir fanden sie indem wir uns in den
Straßen von Medellin die Schuhsohlen
abgelatscht haben um zehn Neins für ein
Jahr zu bekommen
Centro comercial Monterey
in einem Viertel haben wir jetzt fast 20
de Händler in einem Radius von vier
Häuserblocks
jeder neue Händler bekommt nachdem er
eine Einführung bekommen und ein
dashquallet installiert hat einen pay
with Dash Aufkleber und einen kleinen
Dash AirDrop
wir bringen unseren Händlern neue mit
dashzahlende Kunden und führen
direkttransaktionen mit Ihnen durch
die Kunden kleine Mengen an der Schaben
gehen Sie zu den Geschäften zurück und
geben es aus auch wenn wir nicht da sind
in
not there we Supporter wir unterstützen
unsere dash-händler mit einem
beiback-programm so bauen wir vertrauen
auf und erweitern den dashhandel damit
die Händler wissen dass Dash echtes Geld
ist
und dass sie dieser Währung vertrauen
können
mit kostengünstigen digitalen Medien
bauen wir eine Beziehung zu unseren
neuen Nutzern und Händlern auf
und währenddessen entwickelten wir eine
neue Strategie denn Fakt ist normale
Menschen haben keine Zeit stundenlang in
Meetings oder Klassenräumen zu sitzen um
sich detaillierte Vorträge über
blockchain-technologie anzuhören
sie wollen in wenigen Minuten darüber
informiert werden was das Besondere an
Dash ist
und noch viel lieber wollen sie es
selbst kennenlernen und mit uns per
Telefonkontakt halten
also taten wir genau das ich nenne es
die kostengünstige Händler zentrierte
Strategie
wir sind hier mit einer Gruppe von
sandwich-verkäufern
sie hatten zuerst Bitcoin aber es war
einfach zu verdammt teuer und jetzt
nehmen Sie lieber Dash
somewhere ein Teil unserer Arbeit wurde
unabhängig von einem anderen Mitglied
der dash-gemeinde überprüft und was die
Anzahl der dashändler betrifft steht
Kolumbien weltweit an achter Stelle und
dann Platz 2 in Lateinamerika
unsere Events werden größer Händler
kommen zu uns Verkäufer bringen uns neue
Interessenten
wir sind zuversichtlich dass wir in den
nächsten sechs Monaten 450 oder mehr
neue dashändler in Kolumbien haben
werden
und was gibt einer Währung mehr wert als
die Orte an denen wir sie ausgeben
können
danke für eure Unterstützung Juan und
ich schätzen das sehr und wir arbeiten
jeden Tag daran sicherzustellen dass wir
hier in Kolumbien wichtige und sinnvolle
Ergebnisse erzielen
wenn Verbraucher ihr Grip Handy
Auspacken ist schon kryptowährungen
darauf geladen die sie ausgeben oder mit
der sie handeln können ein richtiges
Arbeitspferd zu einem super
konkurrenzfähigen Preis inklusive
kryptowährungen zum verschleudern wie
cool ist das denn krip orientiert sich
an den Bedürfnissen der Menschen in den
drei Amerikas einem riesigen Markt mit
900 Millionen Männern und Frauen in über
20 Ländern Kunden die sich kein 1000
Dollar Mobilteil leisten können vom
Technik versierten aber preisbewussten
16-Jährigen bis zum 40-jährigen
Kleinunternehmer unabhängig von Alter
Geschlecht ethnischem Hintergrund
Ursprungsland oder Beruf des Angebot das
erste Smartphone ist bereits mit
kryptowährung und Krypto wallets
ausgestattet ist für unter 100 Dollar
extrem erfolgreich in Venezuela mit über
66.000 verkauften Geräten
mit dem Konzern um dieses System auch in
Kolumbien umzusetzen
günstige Lösungen wie diese sind
unentbehrlich um Dash zu entwickeln und
voranzubringen ganz besonders in neuen
Märkten wie Medellin
[Musik]
wir hatten diese Woche Trainings und
Beratungssitzungen mit fünf neuen Dash
Marketing-Teams in Lateinamerika
Kolumbien Paraguay Chile Ecuador und
Mexiko
working
Brasilien und Dash Argentinien haben wir
einen Vorschlag erarbeitet eine Dash
lat-am-konferenz am Samstag den 27
Oktober in medelin
Ortega aus dem Dash Team hat es sich zur
Aufgabe gemacht an die zwei Millionen
Menschen starke venezolanische
migrantengemeinde heranzutreten und sie
zu überzeugen Dash für Überweisungen zu
nutzen sie blieben skeptisch aber einer
von ihnen will Dash Wallet produzieren
für Überweisungen von Kolumbien nach
Venezuela
ich half ihm mit Dash Videos die ich im
Februar bei Händlern in Venezuela
gefilmt hatte
inzwischen hat er Spenden von dashboost
bekommen und ich glaube dass er sein
Ziel erreichen wird
das dashlat am Projekt macht dahinter
mit unseren fünf Händlern in Bogota und
Sao Paulo und wir sind mit Teams in drei
weiteren lateinamerikanischen Ländern im
Gespräch
von Dash Sao Paulo und heute haben wir
die erste Veranstaltung mit Dash
Columbia hier in Brasilien
heute bieten wir den Leuten ein
Mittagessen an dass sie mit Dash
bezahlen können kommt also her und lasst
es euch schmecken
[Musik]
in den letzten zwölf Monaten bin ich auf
über 30 Veranstaltungen auf der ganzen
Welt gewesen
aber die meisten von ihnen in
Lateinamerika vier davon in Kolumbien
und ich habe noch keine Gemeinschaft
gesehen die so stark ist wie die Dash
digital Cash Community wenn es um die
Erstellung von Inhalten geht um die
Organisation von Events und die
Anwerbung von Händlern
es gibt immer mehr Veranstaltungen in
Lateinamerika vor allem in Kolumbien und
Brasilien
professionelle Arbeit ist extrem wichtig
um zu zeigen die stark dieses Projektes
und wie das Team dahinter sich bemüht
dass alles wahr werden zu lassen in
einer Weise wie wir es noch nirgendwo
anders auf dieser Welt gesehen haben
inzwischen haben wir mehr Unternehmen
die Dash akzeptieren als die meisten
anderen
kryptowährungsprojekte zusammen
nach einer langen Woche ist es an der
Zeit sich auf den Weg zu machen und
einen erholsamen Tag auf dem Land zu
genießen alle Mitstreiter von dashlet am
und Dash Columbia und viele Freunde sind
gekommen um Zeit miteinander zu
verbringen
aber denkt nicht dass wir hier über
Belanglosigkeiten reden
wir können einfach nicht aufhören über
kryptowährungen blockchain und den
ganzen Papierkram zu sprechen
darüber wie wir die Akzeptanz erhöhen
mehr Bildungsprogramme entwickeln können
und das allerwichtigste wie können wir
all die verschiedenen dash-gemeinden
zusammenbringen
[Musik]
die Hauptfrage ist was ist der wahre
Wert von kryptowährung
er gibt er sich nur aus den Diagrammen
oder aus der Gemeinschaft die dahinter
steht
[Musik]
ich bin mir nicht sicher was ich von
Venezuela erwarten soll es ist das erste
Mal dass ich dort Hinreise aber als
Latino als Brasilianer wird der
Kulturschock wohl nicht allzu groß sein
ich ruhe mich besser mal aus das ist nur
der erste Flug danach warten in Panama
auf Flug Nummer 2 aber bevor wir am Ziel
ankommen werfen wir einen kurzen Blick
in die Geschichte Venezuelas um die
aktuelle Situation vor Ort besser zu
verstehen
[Musik]
beginnen wir mit der Lage Venezuelas
Venezuela liegt an einem strategisch
günstigen Ort auf dem Planeten es
verfügt über 77 Milliarden barrel-öl
Reserven
das brachte Venezuela in eine der
Spitzenpositionen der Länder mit
Ölreserven und das gibt auch jedem
Präsidenten das Gefühl von Macht
wurde 1998 gewählt und galt als der Mann
der Gewinne zu Lana aus der Armut führen
sollte indem er die Ölreserven
Venezuelas nutzte er hatte nur ein Pferd
auf das Servietten konnte und sein Pferd
war Öl weil ein Öl fast damals
durchschnittlich 100 $ kostet der viel
Geld und viel politische Macht
social programs for health er schuf auch
mehrere Sozialprogramme für
Gesundheitsfürsorge Ernährung und
Bildung die alle von der Regierung
bezahlt wurden er verließ sich zu 100%
aufs Öl und vollzog einen massiven
sozialen Wandel in Venezuela mit all dem
Geld und der Macht beschloss Jarvis alle
Unternehmen die mit seiner Regierung
verbunden waren zu verstaatlichen
durch den Kauf aller Banken
zementunternehmen Elektrounternehmen und
viele mehr erlangte der Staat
vollständige Kontrolle über sie in
the mentality time was that und die
Mentalität zu der Zeit war das Venezuela
genug Geld hatte um von Autos über
Lebensmittel Geräte Medikamente Kleidung
landwirtschaftliche Produkte bis hin zu
allem was die Bevölkerung brauchte zu
importieren dabei zerstörte die
Regierung die gesamte
Produktionskapazität des Landes ohne ein
Wirtschaftsmodell oder einem
Geschäftsplan aber der Ölboom dauerte
nur von 2004 bis 2014 2014 und Rücklagen
für die Zeit danach wurden durch die
Regierung nicht gebildet den nordsafe
bei 212
Prozent aus wenn es zu Allers Export
2012 machte der Ölexport 95% der
venezianischen Wirtschaft aus und die
Ölpreise lagen bei über 100 $ pro Barrel
gleichzeitig begann sich der
Gesundheitszustand von Hugo Chavez zu
verschlechtern was Verunsicherung mit
sich brachte
einige andere Länder hörten damit auf
Venezuela Geld zu leihen das Endergebnis
war der Verfall der Landeswährung und
das ganze Land erlebte einen
wirtschaftlichen Kollaps
wenn es will ein Präsident Öko Chavez
hashto tausend
2013 starb Hugo chavers an Krebs und
seine rechte Hand Maduro wurde zum
Präsidenten gewählt
Präsident Maduro erbte ein vom Öl
abhängiges des organisiertes Land von
nun an spielte es keine Rolle mehr wer
das Amt des Präsidenten ausübte
eine Lösung für all die Probleme sollte
nicht leicht und erst recht nicht
schnell zu finden sein
President Maduro ist not will
international community Präsident Maduro
wurde von der internationalen
Gemeinschaft nicht sonderlich geschätzt
gleichzeitig kollabierten die Ölpreise
Venezuela hatte keine Einnahmen mehr und
das verschärfte die Lage zusätzlich
löste sanitäre Katastrophe aus die sich
durch alle Schichten zogen
s die Armut in Venezuela nahm enorm zu
Güter wurden knapp Supermarktregale
blieben leer weil der Ölpreis weiter
sank versankt Venezuela in Schulden die
Regierung hatte nicht genug Geld um
notwendige Dinge wie Lebensmittel oder
Medikamente für die Bevölkerung zu
kaufen innerhalb weniger Tage
verschwanden landesweit weitere Produkte
aus dem Geschäft
[Musik]
schwere Sanktionen der USA machten es
Venezuela zu den unmöglich das Geld
aufzubringen um seine Schulden zu
begleichen und das Land aus der Armut zu
holen from
20007 von 2013 bis 2017 brachte der
Zusammenbruch der Wirtschaft
Hyperinflation die Abwertung der
Landeswährung boliva erhöhte die Armut
zusätzlich und die von der Regierung
angedachte Lösung des Problems bestand
darin mehr Geld zu drucken viel mehr
Geld doch die Leute nahm das nicht hin
2017 wurden über 10.000 Proteste im Land
registriert durchschnittlich 27
Aufstände am Tag
ich reise nach Venezuela um eine soziale
Revolution mitzuerleben die durch
kryptowährung und die blockchain
befeuert wird wo jeder einzelne
Entscheidungsbefugnis hat und nicht die
Regierung oder die Banken willkommen in
der Dezentralisierung welcome the
Synchronisation
[Musik]
ich kann es kaum erwarten endlich in
Venezuela anzukommen mein
brasilianischer Pass wird mir sicherlich
dabei helfen ins Land zu kommen außerdem
hat der schwenezuela unter der Leitung
von urinia Alkali einen straffen
Zeitplan zusammengestellt damit ich all
das sehen kann was das Unternehmen
bereits geleistet hat ich spreche von
einem zwölf Stundenplan täglich 7 Tage
in Folge ich werde die Handelskammer
besuchen ich werde als Referent bei zwei
verschiedenen Konferenzen auftreten
außerhalb des Flughafens wartet schon
der schwenezuela auf mich das Team hat
auch einen Taxifahrer bestellt der
dashcash akzeptiert während der Fahrt
vom Flughafen fällt mir ein Venezuelas
Hauptstadt Caracas eine Sache auf man
sieht überall riesige Reklametafel mit
dem Bild des Präsidenten und seiner
berühmten kryptowährung el patro aber
keine Sorge der steht total Cash hat
unter opinias Leitung auch viele riesige
billboards gebucht und zwar an
strategischen Orten an denen Tausende
von Menschen jeden Tag auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit und zurück vorbeifahren
and the most interestings das
Interessanteste ist dass es auch eine
Hotline gibt unter der man anrufen und
fragen zu Dash tötete Türkei stellen
kann die Nummer wird von der Master Nord
Community finanziert
eines der Community-Mitglieder von Dash
Venezuela zeigt mir wie viel Geld die
für die Taxifahrt vom Flughafen zum
Restaurant in dem wir essen gehen hätte
bezahlen müssen
sie hält gerade einen Betrag von
umgerechnet etwas weniger als 25 US Cent
in den Händen
[Musik]
aber die Taxifahrt haben wir ohnehin mit
der Digital bezahlt
dieser Taxifahrer wird mich jeden Tag
meines Aufenthalts von A nach B bringen
nach einem langen Flug halten wir zum
Brunch dass wir auch mit der
Spezialisten
allein in Venezuela gibt es über 100
Restaurants die heute Dash akzeptieren
man sieht in Venezuela häufig
Menschenschlangen in der Öffentlichkeit
vor Supermärkten sowie vor Banken bei
denen die Regierung den Geldbetrag
kontrolliert den man vom eigenen Konto
der Hausbank abheben darf
ich habe dieses Video online gefunden es
zeigt eine verzweifelte Frau die zu spät
bei der Bank ankam und ihr Bargeld nicht
mehr eintauschen konnte bevor die
Regierung die Währung wechselte aus
Protest zerstörte sie alle Banknoten die
jetzt auf einen Schlag nutzlos geworden
waren das war kein Geld mehr das war nur
noch Papier
[Musik]
ich bin in Caracas Venezuela und hier an
der Tankstelle tanke ich für eine der
Kollegen die mich in der Stadt
herumfahren nur damit ihr es wisst ein
Liter Benzin kostet hier ungefähr einen
Boulevard okay wenn ich das Benzin jetzt
mit einem 5 $ Schein bezahlen müsste
würden Sie mir diesen Batzen hier als
Wechselgeld geben
was ich gerade halte entspricht
umgerechnet etwa 75 Cent in US-Dollar
we need cryptocrossy aus diesem Grund
brauchen wir kryptowährung insbesondere
in einem Land für Venezuela ein Haufen
Geld wie dieser hier hat sich verändert
und ehrlich sagen für einen Dollar
könnte ich hier in Venezuela 6 Monate
lang über 200 Autos volltanken
vorne ist darauf control das gedruckte
Geld ist außer Kontrolle geraten und
Dash ist in über 300 Unternehmen hier in
Venezuela präsent was allen zeigt warum
es wichtig ist eine begrenzte
kryptowährung und ein hervorragendes
Ökosystem wie das von Tash zu haben um
Situationen wie diese zu vermeiden
by Dash digital eine der wichtigsten
Dinge die von der Dash digital Cash
Community in Venezuela entwickelt wurde
ist das Dash Merchant Programm from
dieses Programm war nur eine vieler
Ideen der Dash caracaskonferenz die auch
andere Community-Mitglieder dazu
motivierte eigene Vorschläge zu machen
so dass es ihnen gelungen ist Dash
digital Cash bisher in über 300
Unternehmen in Venezuela einzuführen es
ist ein massives adoptionsprogramm im
ganzen Land das auf Händler ausgerichtet
ist um ihr Geschäft zu verbessern aus
diesem Programm heraus entstand auch
eine Website die es jedem Händler
ermöglicht die lokale Währung boliva in
Dash und US-Dollar umzurechnen und
umgekehrt
[Musik]
so weiß jeder Händler sofort was wie
viel kryptowährung kostet
[Musik]
mein erstes Mal am Venezuela war musste
ich mir selbst erst einmal ein Bild
davon machen wie viele Unternehmen Dash
Akzeptieren von einem medizinischen
Labor das über 50 verschiedene Arten von
Blutuntersuchungen durchführt einem
Elektrogeschäft in dem ihr einen
Fernseher eine Waschmaschine einen
Trockner einen Ofen einen Herd einen
Kühlschrank eine Mikrowelle oder andere
Geräte für zu Hause kaufen könnt
der Filialleiter ist ein so großer Fan
von Dash dass er sogar seine
mitarbeiteruniform mit dem Dash Logo
versehen hat ein Abschleppdienst mit
über 2000 LKWs der rund um die Uhr im
Einsatz ist hat Werder
in cases
auch in einer Modekette für Damen nutzen
Venezuela gibt es sogar einen
Motorradladen in dem ihr Motorräder
kriegt die er mit der bezahlt
Dash Force News berichtete dass sich
über 300 Unternehmen bei Discovery Dash
registriert haben und Dash in Venezuela
akzeptieren was eine größere Zahl ist
als in den Vereinigten Staaten obwohl
die Vereinigten Staaten 300 Millionen
Einwohner haben Venezuela nur etwa 30
Millionen heute gibt es in Venezuela 10
mal mehr Unternehmen die Dash
akzeptieren als in den USA
aber die Dunkelziffer ist eigentlich
noch viel größer Unternehmen tauschen
sich untereinander über die Einführung
von Dash als Bezahlmethode aus eine
Kettenreaktion im Moment weiß also
niemand so genau wie viele Unternehmen
Dash wirklich akzeptieren das System ist
außer Kontrolle sobald Sie den Vorteil
von kryptowährungen erkennen wechseln
Sie sofort dabei haben die meisten
Geschäfte noch nicht einmal das
offizielle Dash Venezuela Programm
durchlaufen
and most important in my favorite meine
Lieblinge Restaurants viele Restaurants
akzeptieren Dash ich habe sieben Tage in
Venezuela verbracht jeden Tag in einem
anderen Ort gefrühstückt zu Mittag und
zu Abend gegessen und mit der bezahlt
von Cafés bis hin zu frühstückslokalen
Happy Hours und natürlich gängigen
Restaurants und teuren Restaurants die
alle Dash akzeptieren
eine der Strategien von der ich
venezuela ist es Ihre Klienten beim
Start zu begleiten sie laden zu
Versammlungen und Fortbildungen in der
Stadt ein hier hat man sich in einem
Café getroffen dass selbst auch Dash
akzeptiert das Thema dieses Treffens war
das food truck-geschäft in Venezuela und
wie der steht Betreibern im
Geschäftsalltag helfen könnte
[Musik]
ein weiterer Vorschlag der von der zuvor
erwähnten Konferenz des der schwenezuela
Teams stammt heißt Dash herb wo es eine
lokale Rufnummer gibt unter der jeder
von Montag bis Freitag von 8 bis 9
Fragen zu Dash sogar technische Fragen
dazu stellen kann
wir sprechen mit den Leiter Alejandro
herzlich willkommen wie geht es Dir
Rodrigo willkommen bei Dash help das
hier ist es das ist unser Support Center
also ja das ist phänomenal weil es ein
echter Bürostandort ist und das ist
nicht alles es gibt noch drei weitere
Räume mit dashändler ja es gibt eine
Küche in der alle Mitarbeiter essen
können und wir haben einen
Besprechungsraum in dem wir jetzt gerade
die Fußball-WM übertragen damit jeder
die Spiele sehen kann
diesen Raum nutzt ihr sonst für
Schulungen und Konferenzen es gibt einen
Beamer wir müssen das ja alles mal
zeigen es gibt eine Rezeption okay lass
uns zunächst einmal darüber sprechen wie
viele Personen hier in Vollzeit
beschäftigt sind
hier bei der Sharp haben wir einen Tech
Manager und vier Mitarbeiter im Büro
haben wir gerade den Tech Manager und 3
supportagenten nachmittags kommt der
andere der vierte supportagent wir haben
also fünf Mitarbeiter im dash-hilfe
Support Center und im der schändler-team
haben wir noch weitere Leute aber wir
sprechen ja gleich noch über das Ding
lass uns auch über das dash-händler-team
sprechen wie viele Leute sind im
dashändler Team
in der schandler-team haben wir gerade
eine neue Person dazu bekommen wir haben
also den Produktmanager den
Verkaufsleiter das sind zwei und wir
haben acht Verkäufer und wir haben zwei
Assistentinnen der Geschäftsleitung die
die Verkaufsagenten im Büro unterstützen
ich denke also 11 bis 12 Leute im
dashcam
das ist ein echtes Dash Büro einen
regelrechter Finanzstandort
es ist wichtig zu erwähnen dass alle
Mitarbeiter mit der SP bezahlt werden
und das ist nicht alles es gibt ja auch
noch die Dash jugendwinnezuela
Dash Jugend venezuela ist eine
Organisation die sich auf die
Verbreitung von Wissen über das
dash-netzwerk und kryptowährungen
konzentriert wir bieten Vorträge an
Schulen und Universitäten an in denen
wir die grundlegenden Aspekte und
Vorteile von Krypto erklären und wie man
das Dash Micro payment Netzwerk als
Lösung für die Situation in Venezuela
nutzen und ein starkes Finanzsystem für
die Zukunft aufbauen kann
die Wirtschaft in Venezuela ist so sehr
zusammengebrochen dass jedes Mal wenn
man die Wörter Geld oder kryptowährung
sagt überall darüber berichtet wird
während meines Aufenthalts wurde ich
eingeladen zusammen mit urhenia in einem
der wichtigsten TV-Sender über
kryptowährung und der Städte Türkisch zu
sprechen für sie war es schon das dritte
mal zu genau diesem Thema auf diesem
Sender in nur einer Woche in Venezuela
wurde ich von über vier verschiedenen
Fernsehsendern und Radiosendern
interviewt die Gründerin von der
Venezuela spricht ständig im Fernsehen
über Dash ist
[Musik]
Venezuela über eine kryptowährung und
ein Zahlungssystem hinaus entwickelt und
ist inzwischen auch ein soziales
Programm zur Inklusion das Dash
venezuela-team gibt Neukunden auf
vorstellungsveranstaltungen ein paar
Dollar zum Test um sich mit dem Thema
intensiver zu beschäftigen dabei
verschenken sie das Geld aber nicht
einfach an sie sondern bringen den
Menschen gleichzeitig bei ein erstes
Wallet herunterzuladen und der ich
darauf zu installieren sie zeigen Ihnen
wie man mit einem Krypto Wallet und
kryptowährung umgeht sobald Sie Ihre
digitale Brieftasche heruntergeladen
haben erhalten Sie sofort das Geld
die Strategie besteht darin Ihnen auch
einen Anreiz zu geben sobald sie das
Geld in Ihrer Brieftasche haben eine der
zwölf Einrichtungen und Sozialprogramme
auszuwählen die bereits bei Dash
Venezuela registriert sind und eine
direkte Spende zu leisten um diese
Einrichtungen zu unterstützen auf dieser
Weise werden die Mittel gut investiert
einerseits um Menschen beizubringen wie
man eine Brieftasche herunterlädt der
ist empfängt und sofort sendet und
andererseits um ein soziales Programm
Umfeld aufrecht zu erhalten dass vielen
Menschen in Venezuela geholfen hat
anstatt Geld kostenlos an irgendjemanden
zu verschenken geht dieses Geld an
spezielle Sozialprogramme in Venezuela
die sogar dazu beitragen Menschen zu
ernähren
die Verwendung von kryptowährung als
Spende für soziale Programme ist eine
weitere Revolution die Dash noch
wiederzuela bringt ihr Geld fließt
direkt an Menschen die es wirklich
brauchen und nicht an große Unternehmen
um marketing-programme oder Boni für
Manager davon zu bezahlen
ein weiteres Programm das ich erwähnen
möchte stammt von einer anderen
Community der ich auch stolz angehöre
einer Bitcoin cash-community sie nennt
sich eat Bitcoin Cash und verwendet das
gleiche Spendensystem jeder kann von
überall ein paar Dollar spenden und
damit helfen die Menschen in Venezuela
zu ernähren IPC venezuela ist so ein
Erfolg dass ein Ableger gegründet wurde
IBC im Südsudan wo es auch eine
humanitäre Krise gibt in der Menschen
verhungern
aber wartet kurz ich bin in den 80er und
90er Jahren aufgewachsen und die meisten
meiner Lieblingsfilme und ich bin großer
Science-Fiction Fan sprechen alle davon
das Computer die Menschheit übernehmen
und sie dominieren und kontrollieren
werden doch im Moment haben wir
Maschinen die Strom brauchen um ein
digitales gut zu schaffen das verwendet
wird um Menschen zu ernähren das konnte
so niemand vorhersagen daran sieht man
mal wie gespalten diese Technologie ist
[Musik]
der Veranstaltungstag ist mein
Lieblingstag der Woche man kann mit
Stolz sagen dass ich über 1.000 Menschen
für den Vortrag und die Präsentation und
die anschließende Dash City angemeldet
haben wenn ihr heute irgendeine Art von
Veranstaltungen Venezuela organisiert
und das Wort Geld in den Mund nimmt
werden tausende von Menschen stundenlang
Schlange stehen um Teil dieser
Veranstaltung zu sein und etwas Neues zu
lernen
[Musik]
bei der Dash digital Cash Konferenz war
das nicht anders in meinem Vortrag ging
es um die Geschichte des Geldes und wie
Brasilien innerhalb von 15 Jahren eine
Inflation von über 1,2 Billionen Prozent
hatte die Regierung änderte den Namen
des Geldes 7 mal Strich 3 Nullen änderte
den Namen des Geldes und druckte neue
Scheine manipulierte die Wirtschaft und
verursachte viele Jahre lang einen
massenchaos in Brasilien wir hatten
sogar einen Präsidenten in Brasilien der
in den 90er Jahren das Geld jedes
Bürgers von seinem Sparkonto in
Brasilien beschlagnahmt hat und heute
geht Venezuela den gleichen Weg wie
Brasilien in den 80er und 90er Jahren
mit Hyperinflation Abwertung das Geldes
und ohne Kontrolle der Geldmenge
and no control of twenty Mini
der Vortrag war ein Erfolg und jetzt ist
es an der Zeit zum coolsten Teil des
Events überzugehen Dash city
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch an die paar Dollar die
jeder während der Veranstaltung beim
einchecken und anmelden für die
Konferenz bekommen hat nun jetzt ist es
an der Zeit das Geld auszugeben Dash
City ist ein gut organisierter
Marktplatz mit über 100 Händlern und
Unternehmen die Dash akzeptieren und der
findet direkt im Anschluss an die
Konferenz statt alle Konferenzteilnehmer
sind begeistert von den neuen
Möglichkeiten die Dash und
kryptowährungen ihnen bieten und sie
haben jetzt die Möglichkeit mit Dash ein
Getränk und eine Mahlzeit zu kaufen oder
etwas Geld draufzulegen und ein paar
Goodies zu besorgen die dieser Markt
bietet das ist das beste Beispiel dafür
wie Dash unternehmensgelder sinnvoll
investiert werden können
das ist Dash city and this is Dash city
[Musik]
nach zehnstündiger Veranstaltung den
Vortrag und Dash City ist es an der Zeit
sich hinzusetzen das Studio einzurichten
und Inhalte für Dash Venezuela und der
Brasilien aufzunehmen the power of
Community wenn es so alles so strong die
Kraft der Gemeinschaft in Venezuela ist
so stark dass sie bis heute über 22
Community Manager hervorgebracht hat die
sich darum kümmern der ich in ihrer
Viertel oder Städte rund um Caracas oder
maracay zu bringen sie erhalten eine
einfache Anleitung von der Venezuela
Tipps dazu wie man neue Partner gewinnt
und den Geschäftsausbau fördern kann sie
verändern die Gesellschaft und
akzeptieren eine neue Art des Geldes wir
haben über 25 Interviews mit Community
Managern geführt und Ihnen eine einfache
Frage gestellt wie können sie
Geschäftsinhaber am besten davon
überzeugen kryptowährungen zu
akzeptieren den Community Manager freie
Hand zu lassen sich auf ihr Umfeld und
die lokale Wirtschaft einzulassen war
die beste Entscheidung von der
schwingezuela
[Musik]
jetzt ist es an der Zeit rauszugehen und
nach marokkai der zweitgrößten Stadt
Venezuelas zu fahren dort wartet ein
weiteres Vorhaben das von der Master not
Community einen Team von Titanen
genehmigt wurde
seine Industrie und die vielen Fabriken
bekannt im Industriesektor des Landes
steckt großes Potenzial für Dash in den
[Musik]
ich wurde eingeladen vor der Handels-
und industriekammer von maracay zu
sprechen und vor etwa 400 Gästen eine
weitere Präsentation zu halten der
beherd
[Musik]
das letzte beginning seit Beginn der
erstbewegung in Venezuela und der
Leitung von Eugenia Alkali und der Dash
caracaskonferenz ist das Interesse an
Dash in dem südamerikanischen Land
explodiert die bargeldähnlichen
Funktionen von Dash für private
sofortüberweisungen mit extrem niedrigen
Gebühren werden als Wegbereiter für
finanzielle Stabilität angesehen neue
Projekte wie Crypto live-ex calibits get
free Dash Venezuela und mehr haben die
Bewegung zusätzlich befeuert das
verbreitet sich im ganzen Land doch das
Thema dieses Interviews mit Hilfe eines
Dolmetschers habe ich mit dem Team
gesprochen dass sich in Venezuelas
zweitgrößter Stadt für die Einführung
von Dash einsetzt und mit einem
vorläufigen Antrag an die Schatzkammer
des Dash Netzwerks ich hoffe euch
gefällt das Interview mit Dash maracay
maracay Team nahm seine Arbeit auf
nachdem der Sohn eines der Mitglieder an
einer der ersten Venezuela Konferenzen
in Caracas teilgenommen hatte und heute
haben sie einen der ambitioniertesten
vorschl für Dash für die ganze Stadt
angeführt von einem Team extremer
Fachleute darunter der CEO der
immobilienkammer der Präsident der
Industrie- und Handelskammer der
Vizepräsident für Immobilien und der
Kammer von Venezuela und dem Direktor
der immobilienkammer
and today aktuell führt man Gespräche
darüber Dash als Zahlungsmittel für alle
Beschäftigten im Industrie- und
Produktionssektor der Region einzuführen
das ist ein weiterer Schritt in Richtung
einer
kryptowährungsrevolution
das die Einführung einer digitalen
Währung durchaus positive Effekte auf
die Stabilität eines Landes haben kann
zeigt sich am Beispiel Venezuela das
Start-up value hilft den Menschen in
Venezuela im Kampf gegen die
Hyperinflation
[Musik]
ich bin Mitbegründer und CEO von value
unser Produkt hilft in venezulanern mit
der Hyperinflation umzugehen und ihr
Geld vor Wertverlust zu schützen
Überweisungen zu erhalten vor Ort zu
bezahlen und um Lebensmittel und
Medikamente zu kaufen
sowohl Unternehmen als auch Verbraucher
sind in der Lage waren und
Dienstleistungen miteinander zu tauschen
und in kryptowährung zu bezahlen unsere
Vision ist es die wirtschaftliche
Freiheit zu erhöhen
venezuela ist bekannt für seine
politische und wirtschaftliche
Instabilität die Hyperinflation hat dazu
geführt dass der boliva in nur zwei
Jahren 99 Prozent seines Wertes verloren
wohlhabende Familien sahen ihr Vermögen
schwinden und einkommensschwache
Menschen wurden noch weiter in die
Verzweiflung getrieben
Simon schamoro kennt diese Geschichte
nur allzu gut
als ich in Venezuela aufwuchs ging im
Grunde alles was mein Vater und meine
Mutter in ihrem Leben aufbauen konnten
verloren als die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrach wir hatten zum Beispiel
Wasserknappheit oder Stromausfälle im
ganzen Land das Geld fing an
hyperinflationär zu werden
das ist keine traurige Geschichte die
ich hier versuche zu erzählen das ist
leider die Realität der meisten
Venezolaner mehr als 99 Prozent der
Venezolaner haben alles verloren was sie
aufgebaut haben weil das Land
gescheitert ist alle Ersparnisse aus der
Mittelschicht die sich etwas aufbauen
wollte lösten sich in Luft auf ich
wollte meine Bestimmung finden und
wusste immer dass ich ein Unternehmen
gründen und Dinge entwickeln wollte
weshalb ich dann auch Industriedesign
studierte ich glaubte fest daran in der
Lage zu sein Dinge zu verändern
letztendlich habe ich diese Karriere
nicht weiter verfolgt aber ich habe eine
Menge Dinge gelernt die mir die
Technologie näher gebracht haben und so
bin ich beim Thema Krypto gelandet ich
habe mich dafür begeistert und als ich
dann das Potenzial von Krypto Verstand
wurde mir klar dass Venezuela der
perfekte Ort ist um solche Ideen in
große Maßstab umzusetzen
der reality ist tatsächlich könnte eine
dekonstruierung der kryptowährung der
Mittelschicht helfen und dieser hat die
Möglichkeit unsere Gesellschaft wie wir
sie kennen grundlegend zu verändern
das Hauptproblem der Venezolaner ist im
Moment die Hyperinflation und diese ist
nur das Nebenprodukt einer totalen
Misswirtschaft dieses Landes
[Musik]
Venezuelas Abstieg in eine verarmte
Diktatur hat der Welt die verheerenden
Auswirkungen der Hyperinflation vor
Augen geführt schleppende
Grundversorgung extreme Knappheit an
Lebensmitteln und medizinischen Mitteln
Bürgerkriege Gewalt
Venezuela die ihre Währung aus Venezuela
in andere stabilere Währungen wie den
US-Dollar transferieren konnten blieben
verschont ein Luxus der meist nur für
die Ultra Elite in Frage kam mittels
kryptowährung möchte Simon mit seiner
Plattform value allen die Möglichkeit
geben sich gegen die Hyperinflation zu
wehren
seiner Meinung nach sind die instabilen
Verhältnisse in seinem Land der
perfekten Nährboden für ein solches
Experiment
niemand traut mehr der Währung oder der
Regierung die Menschen suchen nach
Lösungen
an einem Ort an dem die Menschen
versuchen zu überleben ist die
Hemmschwelle viel niedriger neue Dinge
auszuprobieren sei es diese Dollars
tischmünzen kryptowährungen die Leute
werden bereit sein mit wenig Geld zu
starten und dann langsam versuchen es
irgendwie zu etablieren unser Hauptziel
im Moment als Unternehmen ist es
Händlern zu ermöglichen den Ditto Dollar
als Zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren so
dass die Leute immer weniger gezwungen
sind den Boulevard zu benutzen
wir konzentrieren uns darauf ein Produkt
zu entwickeln das von den Reichen
gebildeten und technisch versierten bis
hin zu den Menschen mit den niedrigen
Einkommen und geringen technischen
Kenntnissen genutzt werden kann in einem
Land wie Venezuela wurde er Mindestlohn
bei ungefähr einem Dollar liegt haben
sie die Situation dass die meisten Leute
ihr eigenes kleines Geschäfte öffnen Hot
Dogs verkaufen oder lokales Essen wie
arrepas oder was auch immer aber sie
verkaufen es vorwiegend in ihren super
riesigen Gemeinden also wollen wir den
Gemeinden helfen Zahlungen in Dollar bzw
in dito-dollar also stable Coins zu
akzeptieren und Nutzer zu erreichen je
mehr Verbraucher in Dollar zahlen desto
besser für die Händler je mehr Händlers
akzeptieren umso besser für die
Verbraucher bis heute haben wir
Millionen von Dollar bewegt und haben
damit mehr als 150.000 Haushalten
geholfen
30.000 aktive Nutzer monatlich und wir
sehen dass es funktioniert in
Wirklichkeit kann wirtschaftliche
Freiheit nur direkt durch Innovation
erreicht werden was kryptow sind
dabei darf man nicht vergessen dass
Venezuela dies bereits versucht hat el
Petro war der Versuch einer
kryptowährung zu etablieren die durch
die reichhaltigste Ressource des Landes
unterstützt wurde Öl während el Petro
weithin als durchschlagender Misserfolg
betrachtet wurde sind sich viele
Experten einig dass dieses Experiment
ein notwendiger Schritt war um eine
digitale Währung für die Zukunft zu
etablieren und Simon ist überzeugt dass
deren Grundlage nämlich die
blockchain-technologie nun stärker denn
je benötigt wird und sein Land bereit
ist für einen weiteren Versuch
die blockchain-technologie ist
tatsächlich eine Art Paradigmenwechsel
für die Menschheit eines der
bedeutsamsten Dinge unserer Zeit
man sieht langsam dass immer mehr
Unternehmen damit beginnen ihre Produkte
komplett auf einer blockchain aufzubauen
es ist fast so als würde sich eine
eigene Wirtschaft entwickeln
wenn es einen Weg ohne Krypto gäbe den
venezulanern ihre Stabilität und
wirtschaftliche sowie finanzielle
Freiheit zurückzugeben wäre das
natürlich ein viel besserer Weg als mit
einem Produkt Erfolg zu haben das in
sich gar keinen Wert besitzt
[Musik]